[Music]
on this Monday night powerful
earthquakes jolting Japan the whole room
was shaking the deaths the devastation
and the
Panic Israel pulling back from Gaza the
reason to release some reservists and
the military's next Focus preparing for
a possible recession in Canada what
money experts say you should do plus a
new year ushers in a new era for sports
we're just as good as the boys the first
professional women's hockey league game
and how the goal for Equity has yet to
be
achieved global national with Donna
freezen reporting tonight Carolyn
Jarvis good evening and thanks for
joining us a powerful 7.6 magnitude
earthquake has rocked Central Japan
killing at least six people with many
more feared
dead
the Quake struck just after 400 p.m.
local time dozens of buildings collapsed
trapping people inside thousands spent
the night in evacuation centers after
the Quake triggered tsunami warnings
along the country's West
Coast the epicenter was in Ishikawa
prefecture but the Quake was reportedly
felt by people in Tokyo 300 kilometers
away dozens of aftershocks have also
been reported some tsunami warnings have
now been lowered though many residents
on the country's West Coast have been
told not to return home netha
reports hey with surreal and scary
sights like this road cracking open many
in Japan started the new year with a
series of strong
earthquakes it is quite scary this
tourist in Japan's hakuba Valley says
he's thankful to be safe the whole room
was shaking the TV was shaking I had to
keep um everything um on the
table according to the Japan meteor
olical agency more than a dozen Quakes
struck in the Sea of Japan near Ishikawa
prompting tsunami warnings for the
length of the country's western
coast the agency initially issued
Japan's highest level Tsunami alert
before downgrading it several hours
later you can see all the snow from the
uh electric wire goes down and also from
the roof F down and all the car is
shaking and so everybody was was
panicked that time the Quake struck just
after 400 p.m. local time starting a
fire collapsing dozens of buildings in
several towns and trapping people
beneath the rubble the government said
more than 97,000 people in nine Coastal
prefectures were evacuated and may be in
shelters for a few days well it's of
course
devastating BC Earth scientist Jessica
polaric who led a research team focused
on Japan's geological history says this
was a shallow event just 10 km below the
Earth's surface contributing to the
scale of Destruction 10 km isn't quite
that much of a distance so there wasn't
really a lot of energy dissipation
occurring in between when the earthquake
happened and when those waves uh seismic
waves reached the Earth
surface more than 30,000 homes lost
power as the country now grapples with
warnings of aftershocks over the next
few days Nara Global News
Vancouver Japan is one of the most
earthquake prone countries in the world
it's located on the so-called Ring of
Fire a string of volcanoes and sites of
seismic activity around the edge of the
Pacific Ocean in March 2011 Japan
experienced the strongest earthquake in
its recorded history the 9.1 magnitude
Quake triggered a deadly tsunami that
killed nearly 20,000 people in the
middle east fighting between Israel and
Hamas did not stop as the rest of the
world rang in the new
year
Sirens blar just moments into 2024 as
Hamas launched a barrage of rockets from
Gaza into Israel right at the stroke of
midnight the group says the attack was
in response to the massacre of civilians
in Gaza Israel says it intercepted 18 of
27 rockets that were fired there were no
reports of
casualties Palestinians inside Gaza also
have little to celebrate for New Year's
as Israeli forces continue their
offensive but there are signals the
assault may be entering a new phase with
Israel announcing it will soon be
withdrawing some of its reservist troops
Redmond Shannon
reports close to 1 million children
inside Gaza are not spending this new
year at home for many the homes they
fled are in Ruins alongside their hopes
for the year
ahead I wish not to die in 2024 says
11-year-old lean we have no bathroom no
food and no water our childhood is
gone above their heads Rockets fired
toward Israel are intercepted Hamas
calling the barrage revenge for Israel's
Massacre of
civilians on the ground fighting rages
into the new year 2 Israel claiming it
killed a Hamas Commander involved in the
October 7th attacks but for the first
time since then Israel's military says
it will pull back on some of its
operations in Gaza withdrawing some
reservists for now to get them back into
their day jobs in Israel's economy and
to move toward more localized attacks on
Hamas Targets in Gaza over the coming
months well I think it's part of the
whole Israeli military plan in Gaza
Street basically it was expected meaning
former Israeli intelligence official ABI
mamad says he expects a focus on the
southern city of can Yunis and the Egypt
Gaza border a Target that Israeli leader
Benjamin Netanyahu says he wants to
control one of the major sources of
Hamas huge incoming um smuggling of
weapons and and ammunitions and many
other things there actually huge massive
network of tunnels that Hamas dug
beneath the Hamas the Gaza and Egypt
border across from gaza's other border
inside Israel Defense Minister Galant
spoke from a kibot devastated in the
October 7th attacks he said members of
some of those communities will be able
to return home soon whether any of those
traumatized survivors will want to go
back is another matter Redmond Shannon
Global News
London Israel's Supreme Court has struck
down a controversial judicial reform
which sparked outrage and Nationwide
protests against the Netanyahu
government last year an 8 to seven
ruling overturned a law that would have
limited the Supreme Court's power to
void government decisions that were
deemed unreasonable a summary of the
Court's decision says the law would
severely damage Israel's democracy prior
to hamas's attack protesters accused the
government of being authoritarian the
law also Drew concern from International
allies the United States meanwhile says
it will be withdrawing the world's
largest warship from the Eastern
Mediterranean Sea the USS Gerald Ford
and it's a comping ships are set to head
home in the coming days they've been on
extended deployment since being
redirected to within Striking Distance
of Israel in response to hamas's October
7th attack they will be replaced by
three other warships heading to the
region at least five deaths have been
reported after a series of New Year's
Day attacks between Russia and Ukraine
in the Russian occupied city of denes
officials say four people were killed
and more than a dozen injured following
what Moscow claims to be heavy Ukrainian
shelling keev meanwhile says Russia
launched record overnight drone attacks
that left at least one person dead and
multiple others injured in the port city
of Odessa it's the latest in a back and
forth series of deadly aerial
bombardments from both sides which
Russian President Vladimir Putin has
vowed to
intensify we have no desire to fight
indefinitely Putin told a room of
injured Russian soldiers today but we
are not going to give up our positions
Putin also called strikes on the Russian
Border City of belgrad that killed 25
people Saturday a terrorist act and
warned of more strikes targeting
Ukrainian military
facilities in his annual New Year's
address Chinese president shiin ping
said Taiwan will surely be reunified
with
China she's comments come just two weeks
before taiwan's next Presidential and
parliamentary elections that could
reshape relations
China has ramped up military pressure on
Taiwan ahead of the elections Taiwan
considers itself distinct from mainland
China and has democratically elected
leaders while China considers Taiwan to
be part of its territory and believes
the two should be
unified over 200 people in the
Netherlands were arrested during New
Year's Eve riots police in several
cities were attacked with fireworks and
Stones authorities in rdam say more than
a 100 Vehicles were set on fire while in
Amsterdam and the ha Riot squads
dispersed violent crowds and a
19-year-old man reportedly died of
injuries from a fireworks incident just
before
midnight here at home the start of the
new year also means a fresh start for
professional women's hockey in North
America it wasn't the start the hometown
crowd was hoping for but history was
made in Toronto nonetheless as New York
and Toronto faced off in the inaugural
game of the new Professional Women's
Hockey League Aran OA was at the game to
catch all the excitement for what many
hope is just just the beginning of a
growing
League the lineup of fans stretched up
the street fans who came to witness
hockey history I'm just excited to like
watch some play the first game the first
game of the new Professional Women's
Hockey League a cello of the former
Maple Leaf Gardens we finally have a
league that's like all together and not
just like a couple different leagues six
teams in a league building itself as the
first of its kind though there has been
some women's Pro Hockey in the past it's
a really big day for women's Rocky and
hopefully we'll grow up and be able to
play in this league players arrive
through the Arena's front door with the
fans something you won't see in other
professional sports it's a great day
Toronto versus New York none of the
teams have names yet or logos that will
happen in the offseason the league says
the key was getting teams on the ice do
not have competing egos or competing
budgets or things like that we are all
in this together players earn an average
of $55,000 a year elite players can to
make $80,000 a year a small number
compared to what male pro athletes make
around the world Billy Jean King before
the game tennis Legend and Advisory
Board member Billy Jean King took the
ice and dropped the puck in the
ceremonial faceof then it was Game Time
the first goal in the new league was
scored 11 minutes in by New York's Ellis
Shelton something to remember in a
trivia contest the League's head of
hockey operations a Hall of Famer
herself said the day is an emotional one
for her for women that played the game
and uh before me in my generation it's
such a proud moment to see we us finally
get to this point New York won the first
game 4 nothing it's huge the idea that
I'm a path maker for a bunch of young
girls going into hockey um it's pretty
exciting that they know that they can
now watch professional women's hockey on
the TV and and grow up to be just like
one of us and Chase that dream of
playing professional the score less
important to fans who wanted a chance to
see some of the best female male players
people shouldn't think that we we aren't
as good as the boys I think that we're
just as good as the boys and now a
professional League to prove that Shan
OA Global News
Toronto and now a professional League to
prove that Shan OA Global News
[Applause]
Toronto and in professional men's hockey
the NHL held its annual Winter Classic
in Seattle with the city's Kraken and
the Vegas golden kns playing around with
fashion Seattle Dawning some gear
honoring the city's popular Fish Market
while Vegas dressed as who else but the
king Elvis Presley
himself money is top of mind for many
Canadians coming up how experts say you
can be ready for a recession just in
case one
hits well the holidays may have been a
good excuse to splurge a bit but if
you're among the countless Canadians
bracing for your credit card bill
perhaps your New Year's resolution will
be about getting into Financial shape
that could mean paying down debt
boosting your savings or investing
wisely and gaviola has more on how to
make the most of money related
resolutions new year new Financial
landscape money experts say 2024 should
include preparing for the recession many
economists have been predicting in a
recession the best thing that you can do
is have manageable debt payments so if
you were to lose your job or if your
income was to slow down could you still
pay your mortgage could you still make
your debt obligations this personal
finance expert says slaying or taming
debt should be top of mind for many
households if debt isn't dragging you
down creating or beefing up your
emergency fund is a good idea just in
case we really are stressed out about
finances particularly at this time of
year new polling by ipsos exclusively
for global news shows the number one
thing people are worried about is money
as holiday bills roll in nearly 70% say
they can't absorb unexpected costs of
$1,000 or more about 2third worry
they'll have to delay future plans or
life projects like buying a home or
starting a family 55% are anxious about
being able to pay their full credit card
bill more than half Fred about affording
gas as well as having enough to feed
their family food inflation is expected
to moderate but prices will mostly keep
Rising in 2024 experts suggest finding
ways to reduce food waste and save money
by avoiding prepared food whether it's
watermelon that's already cut or it's
meals that are already cooked and and
fresh that you can just warm up
definitely a great convenience but you
pay a premium for that convenience
remember recession proofing your
finances means sticking to your
investment plan even if the headlines
make you nervous even though you might
be reading extra extra there's a
recession in Canada
stock markets can be going up stocks
tend to look 6 months down the road and
anticipate what's to come not what is in
the past Ann gaviola Global News
Toronto when a sandwich is not just a
sandwich still ahead the latest culinary
Trend sparking lineups in
Montreal Montreal's culinary scene may
be best known for its bagels and smoked
meat but there's a new trend sweeping
the city Italian sandwich shops are
popping up all over drawing huge lineups
of hungry customers as Dan Spectre
reports while business has never been
better the tradition started long
ago it's not even noon and the lineup at
Bosa in Verdun is already starting to
swell day after day crowds gather to
devour chef and founder Daniel L's
succulent sandwiches it's like
Controlled Chaos almost like a ballet or
a dance now in its sixth year the shop
pumps out hundreds of sandwiches daily
on a sunny day people line up down the
block for L's Italian inspired Creations
just like a really nice feeling it's
emotional it's like incredible to see
everybody here lining up for like the
food that you've created the winning
formula here is one that's been refined
over Generations a key inspiration his
grandfather Pasqual vesio who immigrated
to Canada from Italy in the 60s he came
here with three kids uh wife no money in
his
pocket business is also booming a few
kilometers away at Clark Cafe where
Frank cadio pays tribute to his late
grandfather with every scrumptious
sandwich that's my grandfather Sal the
late salvator sadio founded buang Clark
in 1980 it was an Italian Community
staple for 35 years I just always had
like the idea of bringing the Clark
brand back the skyh high popularity of
both Clark and Bosa has contributed to
an explosion of modern Italian inspired
sandwich and coffee shops opening across
Montreal strip away the Chic design and
glossy Instagram posts and you get the
NDG Bakery founded in 1974 by the late
veto deito he started like maybe 8 n
years old as a baker it's still run by
veto's children who work tirelessly to
honor his vision the Tomato pizzas
Breads and pastries play a Star in role
but Angie sanlon will make you a
sandwich that can compete with any other
Marella ke Co salami and cheese and he
took some hot peppers Nikki DeVito is
not surprised the art of the Italian
sandwich is finding a new audience in
Montreal it's like a classic you're
having a sandwich it's different you
know you're going to have a pruto
sandwich you're going to have a a
chicken cutlet so whether you prefer to
be served Italian Perfection by one
generation or
another rest assured that there's a
healthy serving of family history and TR
addition in every bite Dan Spectre
Global News
Montreal unusual ice sport next how
winter isn't taking the wind out of an
Alberta man's
[Music]
sails in a winter where skiers and
snowboarders are lamenting the lack of
snow there is one sport that is
celebrating the conditions ice sailing
never heard heard of it well neither had
we and what might strike you as equally
curious is the place it's taking off
landlocked Alberta Sarah Ryan takes us
aboard LOL Ross has been ice sailing in
and around Edmonton for the last 35
years you're taking something that isn't
really a boat it looks more like a
narrow Hull or like in my case it looks
more like a platform and you've got two
blades back and one in the front and
you're using uh sails yes he said says
ice ceiling is an adrenaline rush once
you have your momentum built up there's
a real thrill of traveling at 20 30 4050
K but the conditions have to be just
right you need at least 4 in of barren
ice and at minimum a steady 15 kilm an
hour Breeze this Winter's lack of snow
has also been excellent particularly
cooking lake and some of the other ones
around here are quite shallow so they
could freeze up and technically uh you
could be on the ice sailing even in
October Ross thinks if more people knew
about the sport they'd become addicted
to the thrill once they've tried it and
realize that it's not an exotic
expensive sport they might get the
bug that was certainly the case for New
York resident Paul
Chamberlain I always look forward to an
opportunity to go ice boating and we'll
actually drive thousands of miles to
make it happen this fall Chamberlain
drove from Albany newor New York to an
ice booat builder in Detroit to an ice
booat swap meet in Minneapolis and then
finally to St Paul Alberta for the
perfect ice there's still no sailable
ice down here well we used to get it mid
December uh but with the warming Trend
in the world here we're we're we're no
longer getting it till till January he
recently started getting into
competitive
races even when you're going slow like
15 M an hour it's still fun and when
you're going 40 miles an hour it's still
fun but you're starting to be a little
nervous they always wear helmets just in
case hoping to see the sport grow
Chamberlain plans to host an Alberta ice
sailing cup next fall we have two people
grade we have 20 people that'd be better
so very much looking forward to
promoting uh ice boating in Alberta
Sarah Ryan Global
News and that is global national for
this New Year's Day I'm Carolyn Jarvis
tonight's your cada is a chill Challenge
and a New Year's
tradition oh you're braver than me
Canadians put last year on ice with a
Polar Bear Plunge dipping themselves
into frigid Waters despite Sub-Zero
temperatures across most of the country
thanks for watching hope you'll join us
again tomorrow
[Music]
night
oh